today's video is actually three shorter
video split up into different sections
of one video or as I like to call them
parts here's the first one enjoy so I
have a friend called Grace who works in
social media at Disney and this is the
same grace by the way who let me go to
Pixar Animation Studios to meet the
director of Toy Story 3 that one time
she's a good one she is I like her
apparently she's trying to promote the
new Muppet movie blesser and so she
asked me how I would like it if she got
the people who make the Muppets to make
a muppet version of me and so now I have
this in my life
that's what they do right this is the
official charlie is so cool like Muppet
which if I'm honest doesn't really look
much like me at all
well you don't really look much like me
either then turn the quiz on there one
thing they did get right is the mole on
his cheek
I do enjoy that quite a lot and apart
from that I don't have orange skin nor
do I have ginger hair and as far as I'm
aware I don't wear blue eyeshadow
although the nose is pretty accurate
because I do have a cold at the moment I
was actually thinking of getting him
like a little skull t-shirt to wear so
that it would be more obvious that were
meant to be the same person but um they
didn't have one in your size which he's
um obviously very sad about as much as
he doesn't look anything like me though
it is just really nice having a puppet
you know I'm finally getting all of the
affection that I crave some silly things
that I've enjoyed making him do so far
include but are not limited to getting
him to hit himself in the head making
him pull this facial expression and
getting him to transition from normal to
extremely shocked
in fact when I'm not using him he
naturally has that really shocked
expression on his face which is great
because it means that every single time
I put him down on the floor he looks
like he's been murdered part two it's
time for another challenge Charlie I
think it was finally time for me to
start learning how to write this thing
my unicycle this was a challenge
submitted by 22 jpo 22 thanks JP but
this is probably gonna be more of a
unicycle in part 1 as I don't think it's
likely that I'm actually gonna be able
to ride this thing by the end of today
or so you might have noticed that I'm
not wearing any safety equipment
whatsoever so if you would like to learn
how to ride a unicycle don't do it like
this because I'm an idiot first step
seems to be that you just get on the
thing and try not to fall
so let's do that though know which side
is the front and which side is the bank
oh that's fun huh backwards is not as
fun backwards it's not as fun oh I
really wonder whose idea it was to make
this stupid thing yeah I'm gonna come at
you now
I think face first yeah at least still
don't know if I'm sitting on it the
right way around ah ah yeah oh that's
right
broke a couple of weeks into January now
and so it's been long enough that
everybody else has already made their
videos about their new year's
resolutions but even though I am a
little bit late I still would like to
share my resolutions with you because eh
I've actually been sticking to them so
far this year so that's good and B there
is one of them in particular that I'm
just really excited just to tell you
about I have three the first one is just
get healthy Lowell because I did find
myself with a little Podge belly after
Christmas this year my second
resolutions a bit better it's just do
more nice things for other people
because I felt like I was focusing a bit
too much on myself and making choices
that just made me happy and I wanted to
make other people happy because I'm only
one person and other people a billion so
they are more important so my final
resolution the one that I'm really
excited about is that this year I
decided that I was gonna write a feature
film not because anyone's told me to
just cuz that's what I want to do it
might seem a bit crazy cuz I've never
actually written anything that's lasted
longer than about five minutes before
and a film is 90 minutes long at least
but I started just a couple of weeks ago
and I'm just enjoying myself so much I'm
not gonna tell you what it's about
because hopefully you'll find out when
the film gets made which is definitely a
thing that's gonna happen it is possible
I guess that it might just be completely
rubbish but I'm having fun and I wanted
to tell you that that was what I was
doing this year that's the end of part 3
which coincidentally is also the end of
the video you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
as much um Oh God you and your stupid
stick
Oh